good morning john so there is a way in
which this is you know not maybe the
best time to have a charity live stream
it's a messy world and we all want to
know what's happening what happened what
it all means i mean this is i guess this
is somewhat every day we feel like this
and as always lots of people have
opinions and sometimes they're so strong
that they present them as facts but
here's the situation no one knows what
the future holds and i think that that
can make it difficult to focus on
anything in particular but there are
also ways in which this is a really good
time to have a live stream john it's
been years now since you have started to
say to me a thing that is definitely
true and then i believe which is that
like it's very easy to focus on the the
thing that is happening right now while
ignoring more long-term crazies and so
those long-term things that are really
big deals don't feel like big deals
because they're always there and so
those problems get solved more slowly
than otherwise maybe they could but
catherine said something else to me this
morning that i had never heard while we
were walking around our neighborhood
talking about
how
you know i was talking about
particularly how powerless i felt in the
moment you know a common feeling i think
and she said this amazing thing that
there aren't really any problems
that aren't connected to the other
problems so when you're working on
something you're kind of working on
everything especially because like
ultimately there is one thing that we're
all trying to do like there's one big
thing it's to make the world better so
as long as the thing you're working on
makes the world better you are doing the
thing that we're trying to do which is
to make the world better not perfect
better during the first half of the
project for awesome we're raising money
for partners in health and save the
children these are two organizations
that have proven themselves be quite
good at looking at long-term crises and
staying focused on them so that the
world can get better partners in health
employs over 17 000 doctors operating in
11 countries focused on everything from
cancer treatment to preventing
malnutrition and save the children has
been operating for over a hundred years
providing emergency response education
programs health programs and advocacy in
2020 they supported nearly 200 million
children and helped 12 million children
gain access to quality education this is
a big world with big problems and these
are two organizations that have proven
strategies to help make things better
and when you go to project for
awesome.com donate you can get so many
different amazing things in exchange for
your donations and all of it is only
available during the project for awesome
also this is the 15th project for
awesome it's also the 15th year of
vlogbrothers so a nerdfighter named jim
is making a bunch of these laser-cut
wall plaques the ones that you will get
will say 50 years of vlogbrothers here
so i'm looking forward to some donations
for these so we can send some of these
out to people in my opinion we have one
of the best slates of p4a perks ever
this year the designs are just really
good and make me very happy so many
things are challenge coin the socks the
poster the stickers a really beautiful
deck of cards and for the first time
ever the project for awesome puzzle
which looks amazing i love puzzles this
looks like a fun one we've also of
course got lots of digital perks that
are all lumped together into the digital
download bundle and that this year
includes both all of my tick tock drafts
over the last year and also all of
john's including the ones that john
posted for a little while and then
immediately took down this is i'm not
kidding over 200 total tick tocks if you
get both and you do get both if you get
the digital download bundle we also have
matching donors right now which means
that every dollar you donate gets
doubled so you can go to project for
austin.com donate right now we're also
going to have matching donors during the
second half of the project for awesome
when we're going to be raising money for
organizations that are voted on by this
community at projectforawesome.com and
of course during this whole thing we're
going to be having a lovely little live
stream here at youtube.com vlogbrothers
which you can also find at
projectforawesome.com live all of the
relevant links are in the description
john i'll see you today